dear fellow citizens
tonight we are not only at the beginning of
a new year but also of a
new decade
i am convinced we have good reasons to be
confident that in
a few hours you can start the 20s
of the twenty-first century good
years if we use our
strengths  benefit if we focus on
what connects us if we
remember what we
have achieved together over the past decades
next year germany will
be reunited in peace and freedom for 30 years
in these 30 years we have achieved
great things such as
had  never before have so many people
worked as today but there will
still be more to do in the next decade than
we thought 30 years ago
at the same time we experience every day how
much digital progress is changing our lives in
all areas of course our working life too
we have to find new answers to this
because we want that  s everyone has
access to the education they
need for this change we want
them to continue to have a good
and secure job in the future and
a reliable pension
for this we need more than ever the courage
to think in new ways the strength to leave familiar paths
the willingness to dare something new and the
determination to act faster
in the conviction that the unusual
can and must succeed if it should still be possible for
the generation of today's young people
and their descendants to
be able to live well on this earth
the warming of our earth is real
you  is threatening they and the
crises that have arisen from global warming are
man-made
so we must also do everything
humanly possible to meet this
challenge to humanity
it is still possible this
conviction is also supported by the
climate protection program that the federal and state governments
passed a few days ago
i know very well  that the inside
measures
that have been decided make you afraid that they
could overwhelm you and
not be enough for the others
and that's true, too, at the
age of 65 i am at an age where
i personally will no longer
experience all the consequences of climate change that
would occur if the
politics doesn't act it's our
children and grandchildren who
have to live with the consequences of what we do or don't do today that's
why i use all my
strength to ensure that germany
makes its contribution ecologically economically
socially to get climate change under control the law
that has just been passed
offers the necessary framework in the literal sense of the word
we can build on what
has always made us strong
our ideas our inventive
spirit our diligence and persistence
our craftsmen engineers and
specialists our state and
voluntary structures our way
of living together in families and
associations  the appreciation for
those who work, for example, in the
care of other people and with
other people, and in doing so
, we are supported by the values ​​of the basic law
of freedom, solidarity and respect for the dignity
of every individual as well as
the principles of the social
market economy,
they will remain our compass in the
next  decade that means even in the
digital age, technology has
to serve people and not the other way around
human dignity sets the limits
because it is inviolable
that is the core of our liberal
democracy that has to be filled with life every day
thank you to the women and men who  in
our country
take on political responsibility, especially in the
municipalities protecting you, like everyone else in
our country, from hostility and
violence from racism and
antisemitism is the task of the state a
task to which the federal government
feels particularly committed
i would like to thank the many who have supported  our
g  employing the community full-time and on a
voluntary basis the police officers
firefighters and all those who help their
fellow human beings in difficult situations
they all form the backbone of our
democracy dear fellow
citizens in recent years
i have often said that
germany only does well in the long run if europe does too
it works well because only in the
community of the european union
can we assert our values ​​and interests
and secure peace, freedom and
prosperity
europe must make its voice heard more in the
world
we will also campaign for this during the
german council presidency in the
coming year, for example
through a summit  of all
member states with china and a
meeting with the states of africa
cooperation with africa is also in
our own interest because only if
people have the chance of a peaceful
and safe life will flight
and migration decrease only if we
fight wars through political  ical solutions will end
, sustainable security will
set in.
our security and our prosperity
depend to a large extent
on our neighborhood also becoming safe and
economically prospering,
so tonight i would like to thank
our soldiers, the
police officers and
the civilian helpers  those who are
far from home are doing their job
dear fellow citizens a
new decade is ahead of us the 20s
can be good years
let us surprise ourselves once again with
what we can make
changes for the better are possible
if we openly and resolutely
engage in new things
in this sense  I wish you
and your families a healthy happy and
blessed new year 2020
[music]